[Music]
why does daredevil bother trying to
enter the church from the roof where's
the access point you only got this role
because you were on The Sopranos cliche
don't curse kid is comfortable enough to
swear in front of his father and is
immediately told not to curse cliche
giant moon over the skyline effects
brought to you by Bruce Almighty never
trust a report card with a typo that
just happens to run into his dad shaking
somebody down in an alley behind the
police or used to work this final
destination how many barrels of
biohazardous material does Matt have to
navigate through to run away from his
disappointing dad Matt sighs require a
fortnight to travel their entire death
why did a biohazard chemical blind his
eyes but improve his hearing by like a
thousand percent because if it was just
that going blind boost sure other senses
thing that did it then why don't all
blind people have like this visual radar
hearing ability the most amazing of all
my sense of sound gave off a kind of
radar sense since since since since
since since since these bullies waited
like six months in between beatings geez
did this referee just start counting at
the number 10
boxing is so rigged that a fighter that
was supposed to take a dive wins
dishonestly there aren't thorns inside
the actual rose flower only on the stem
and you can clearly see that he doesn't
grab any of the stem and his fists so
there shouldn't be any blood coming out
I would keep my promise I would help
those that others wouldn't I would seek
justice
I thought the promise was just that you
would go to law school eh and never give
up daredevil sleeps in water but doesn't
wake up with wrinkly skin movie came out
in the age of debit cards but has
Murdoch using cash so we can get more
reminders about how he's blind you son
enjoyed every minute is there any more
guilty sounding sentence for an accused
rapist to say while on the witness stand
what does he do on the nights when the
window washers don't leave their hanging
on the building at perfectly spaced
intervals for jumping like does he ever
jump off the building and go oh the
window washers put away their stuff if
the chemicals supplied to them also give
him super jumping ability you just
jumped like 50 yards pointless pg-13
pseudo nudity a dozen guys with guns
can't hit a blind guy in a shiny red
suit bad guys shoot daredevil while he
jumps down but then forget how guns work
when he lands yet another heroes
surrounded by bad guys but ganging up on
him never occurs to anyone you don't
have to be daredevil to follow any of
this poorly lit and rapidly edited fight
see even daredevil would have to admit
that beating asked a Nickelback is
pretty lame back to guns here machine
guns no less but somehow even worse aim
everyone ran out of bullets again back
to punching casada runs out of the bar
and for some reason daredevil that
allows him to leave apparently so that
he can run all the way back up to the
roof and jump all the way back down
again a standard ever walks down the
stairs the countdown time on the clock
goes from 155 to 137 in the next shot
supposedly a train is coming into the
station but it never stops and there's
no Express track going through this
station then oh so conveniently yet
another train comes through not even a
minute later so that daredevil can be
temporarily driven insane by the noise
and it also doesn't stop the MTA is
addicted New Yorkers go to hell how long
do you have to wait to pull the trigger
after telling someone to go to hell
daredevil is a straight-up murderer
whatever his motives he's no hero he's
part of the problem hopefully if he knew
this was gasoline and he threw fire at
it anyway with a bunch of cops standing
around
that's totally a crime and also how the
fuck did he know that also non visionary
comic-book adaptation director rips off
the crow oh come on no amount of
unexplained regular hearing will help
him accomplish this bull to fully
horrible movie foreshadows an even worse
movie to come later no Jennifer Garner
is hot and all but she gets his coffee
in the time it took Matt to get up from
the table and walk over to the couch
what is the point of this do we need
proof right off the bat that kingpin is
a bad guy how's your daughter okay
I take it back maybe that's a more
guilty sounding sentence for an accused
rapist to say while on the witness stand
my name's elektra natchios she sounds
like a Mexican appetizer movie thinks it
could absolve itself of a really stupid
character name by making a joke about it
and a kind of racist joke at that so
anyone whose heart beats faster is lying
and anyone whose heart dozen is telling
the truth
what about a bad crazy person that
thinks they're telling the truth or a
person on drugs or just a really good
liar
these people are going to call the cops
now right why was this dickhead cabbie
speeding through this street anyway the
traffic is obviously slow-moving right
here and he was gonna have to put on his
brakes anyway okay thanks
sir no need to check anything else I
guess enjoy your flight I don't know why
anyone bothers to lock anything in
movies when they can be unlocked by
anything straight in metal I understand
the cop was found to be lying but when a
murder case happens isn't there a team
of detectives that check out the victims
apartment later shouldn't there have
been evidence that Matt could look over
without having to break in when it rains
it's like there's a rooftop on the world
just then it's like you can already see
with the radar hearing thing I know this
is a movie but this is literally the
second time they've met and about the
15th minute they've spent together so
wait this fight started while Matt was
kissing Elektra and then he leaves as
supposedly goes to his apartment to put
on the daredevil costume comes back and
this fight is still going on and the
kingpins henchman is still asking the
same stupid questions
discount older fatter Eminem I'm not the
bad guy by my count we're halfway
through the movie and you've committed
murder stalking assault breaking and
entering and evidence tampering
you are the one who knocks bro
throughout this scene Favreau's tossing
this ball back and forth to himself and
there are definitely no spare balls in
the table right below this picture and
near his coffee but then after he shoots
it he suddenly has a couple spares
sitting there so he can still have
something stupid to do with his hands
during the scene I promise nothing bad
is gonna happen I promise cliche so
bullseye was hired to kill nachos but
how do you know that they would be in a
limo going down the street at this very
moment and why would kingpin hire a guy
all the way from Ireland to do something
almost any assassin could have done when
the limo wrecks into the New York Post
truck there are no papers all on the
Left driver's side of the limo but then
in subsequent shots there are papers
everywhere
evanescence I know I know how you feel
you don't know how I feel cliche Wow
the odds that Matt would take a cab with
the exact same serial numbers as the one
he passed walking in the street earlier
in the movie every number and letter in
a sequence can be rotated 180 degrees to
be something completely different cliche
even in 2003 this looks like the fakest
website ever created who's dropping
these bags of sand are they gonna timer
of some sort how much preparation does
that take to set up and why isn't she
doing outside so she doesn't make so
much of a damn mess I know daredevil has
some acrobatic skills but the laws of
physics still apply right how can you
jump up a building like this without
building up any speed seriously this was
a surprise
are these people in the matrix the
helicopter cops actually have to
identify that they're air cops as
opposed to street cops before arresting
someone this is supposedly to get us
back to where we left off in the
beginning but everything in the
background has changed there was a huge
wall and background and the Empire State
Building and tons of other stuff and how
did he get to the top of the church
again there are no neighboring buildings
where he could have jumped onto the
church's roof and if he merely climbed
the church why did he he's just gonna go
inside anyway
I understand bull design is amazing at
throwing things and hitting the target
but I was unaware he was amazing at
finding people in random locations
so we daredevil can fly now I mean why
does he even need grappling hook some
movie unintentionally inspire spider-man
three okay so we know bull's-eyes deadly
accurate throwing everything so this is
total bull the daredevil backflips in a
straight line and manages to invade
every single projectile the bullseye
droves a movie unintentionally inspires
an entirely different part of spider-man
three like they're just gonna let her
reporter drive his personal vehicle
right up to the front door of the sealed
off building they're about to have the
SWAT team enter bull's eye villain just
so happens to have an office with water
running through it so that when it
springs a leak
Daredevils raindrop eyesight kicks in
I'm not the bad guy
see now that he's learned it's wrong to
kill he's ready to play Batman in a
movie universe where Superman rips
people's heads off mad G's does Matt
have a homing beacon on him or something
[Music]
all the time down at the docks fastest
history ever since cinemasins began the
most requested thing has been TV since
and now it's a reality click the link in
the description below to check it out
and now the audio outtakes
[Applause]
hear that mr. Anderson that is the sound
of inevitability to the sound of
goodbye mr. Anderson
[Music]